oh  I love that smell makes me hungry when I  when I smell it hello hello do you make  salads yeah yeah I'll do a frozen Bowl  yeah that works can I do uh turkey only  turkey can you give me triple meat Just  Turkey perfect it's like a buffet  protein I might just eat this for dinner  is that triple meat that's three yeah no  [ __ ] not a lot can I go four let's go  four meat portions it's light just  lettuce and then banana peppers we can  throw some Jalapenos in there too thank  you actually you can put tomatoes in  there too that'd be great yep just a few  nope no sauce actually the first time I  saw this where it looks like it's full  of cookies because of the sheet I  thought that was really clever it gives  the feel of inventory  tonight thank you 45 grams of protein  and 400 calories